the goat simulator franchise isn't new
to trollish Antics but a recent ad for
Goat Sim 3 took those Antics to another
level by including gameplay from the
massive GTA 6 leak that emerged earlier
this year the ad which is currently
unavailable featured a humorous overview
of an NPC named Sean who describes his
duties as walking around in circles
picking things up and sitting on a bench
the GTA 6 clip comes in late in the ad
when Sean says that you can see him in
some quote footage that was leaked a
couple months ago GTA publisher takes
who did not find this bit funny at all
and it didn't take long for the company
to issue a dmca notice to take down the
video the fact that the goat simulator
developers responded to the original
tweet with the I'm in danger gift from
The Simpsons indicates that they
probably knew what they were doing here
it remains to be seen if Take 2 will
take further legal action Beyond just
the dmca notice and hopefully coffee
stain North can survive any potential
Reaper cushions from such a giant and
speaking of surviving sorry that's the
best transition I got it's the end of
the year give me a break the director of
Star Wars Jedi Survivor recently spoke
with Game Informer and explained
features we can expect from the upcoming
game there are a total of five
lightsaber stances including a dual
blade stance and one where Cal wields
both a lightsaber and a blaster a new
heavy and slow stance uses a cross guard
lightsaber as introduced by kylo Ren
these new stances will let you hit
harder and from farther away but whether
you should use them depends on the
enemies you will be facing Survivor will
also offer more options for travel
allowing for a quote wider metroidvania
approach you can use an Ascension cable
to climb walls or cross gaps tame and
ride mounts and use a variety of skills
to hop across Unthinkable barriers
protagonist calcus will also gain some
AI assistance in the form of mercenary
bowed Acuna hopefully I said that
will help you in both combat and
traversal the first Gameplay trailer for
Jedi Survivor debuted at this year's
game awards and revealed a March 17 2023
release date but if you want to play a
space game right now look no further
than high on life the wacky and wild
shooter from squanch games is tearing it
up on Xbox game pass Benji sales on
Twitter found a list that showed the new
game from Rick and Morty's Justin
royland as the number one most popular
Xbox game pass title earlier this week
the game's own Twitter account re-shared
the Tweet Microsoft subsequently
confirmed that high on life is Xbox game
pass's biggest release of 2022 and the
biggest third-party launch of all time
on a Game Pass it's also the biggest
single player game launch on Game Pass
history Microsoft said quote those stats
are measured in terms of Engagement
based on the number of hours played in
the first five days of release we gave
the game a 7 out of 10 here at Gamespot
and if you've got some free time over
the holidays I definitely recommend you
check it out I've already beaten the
game so I'll be heading to other games
on close to finishing like say Pokemon
Scarlet thanks for watching Gamespot
news in 2022 and we'll see you again
next year